[Music]
it's hard to find a toy that's more
recognizable and love than the simple
lego brick
the danish company behind it is one of
the world's largest toy makers
lego also operates several popular
amusement parks including the newest
the legoland new york resort about an
hour north of new york city
jamie wax dropped by just before they
opened the gates and shows us how they
were a model
of persistence keeping the project going
even during the pandemic
all right it looks like we're about to
go
[Applause]
at the legoland new york resort as the
theme song to the lego movie says
everything is awesome and melt them down
so these are etf
tracklists including professor brick's
whimsical factory adventure
is this ride favorite attraction at the
at the park oh by far
kale elliott was part of the design team
for the attraction
which makes visitors feel like they've
been shrunken into a minifigure
the 150 acre theme park features seven
lands built around
signature lego sets like ninjago
and pirates what are you proudest of
you have put into practice and designed
the rewarding part of the job is when
guests first step onto those rides and
you first see their
joy and the surprise and the excitement
of flying down the roller coaster
going through a ride for the first time
those are the proudest moments for me
here children drive the experience
and use their imaginations for custom
creations
but even big kids like me can find
thrills too
oh boy we're in for a drop here we go
here it goes
[Music]
the lego story began in the 1930s
in the workshop of danish carpenter ole
kirk christensen
the signature brick in its present form
was launched in 1958
the lego brick twice named toy of the
century has cemented itself
in pop culture
[Music]
and in the hearts of fans of all ages
at lego land in new york the bricks
transport visitors
all over the big apple with large-scale
models
and as difficult as it is to imagine
assembling the over 30 million bricks
used here at the resort
because of coven these bricks weren't
the only things that were difficult to
assemble
the pandemic certainly through a monkey
wrench into
our construction timeline and our phased
opening our master model building
divisional director stephanie johnson
says supply chain challenges caused
months of delays
parent company merlin entertainment
spent 500 million dollars on the project
and received 15 million dollars in state
grants
there are hopes that the park and a new
250 room hotel
will drive tourism to the region this
area
is affectionately known sometimes a
slow-motion goshen
why here yeah so it's been an
interesting journey it was always our
goal to have
a theme park in the northeast we landed
on goshen
not only because of its beautiful
picturesque setting but also because it
was close to new york city
legoland has taken great pain to tell us
what they're giving us
they keep saying this opportunity of a
lifetime we're doing it for you goshen
no you're not part-faced opposition in
the form of lawsuits
filed by locals concerned about zoning
and the environment
it was hit with more than 600 thousand
dollars in fines for dozens of
environmental violations
including for muddy storm water washing
from the construction area
into a nearby creek you have a new sort
of
approach and purpose in environmental
causes related to the park with any
project of this size there's certainly
lots of things to consider we've done
many environmental studies and we
continue to partner with all of our
local contractors
with independent consultants both from
the town from the state and
frankly all local municipalities to make
sure that we are a good community
partner what do you say to parents who
are a little concerned about
bringing their families out and
experiencing something like this
at this moment so at legoland new york
our number one priority is health and
safety
we are operating under a reservation
system
which means we are limiting capacity to
encourage social distancing
will have the opportunity to virtually
queue they won't have to wait on a
crowded line
they'll have the opportunity to order
their food from their mobile device and
so it's really about encouraging that
contactless journey so you can stay with
your family enjoy
and have fun we'll always have a break
now yeah
summer break is the best right it is
he's in third grade i'm in first
mom lauren wegner eight-year-old mason
and five-year-old ali are season pass
holders
what does it mean to you after the
pandemic and
a year plus of sort of isolation to be
out
in this beautiful very sunny day and see
people with no mass and have your
children be able to experience this it's
a breath of fresh air and a long awaited
breath of fresh air we've all been so
excited to actually
experience things as a family and have
nice time together walking around you
get a sense that
the kids and the adults both needed it
right yes
yes and now all the adults are being big
kids here too
building a bridge back to pre-pandemic
times
brick by brick or cbs this morning
saturday
jamie wax legoland new york
i'm in i'm all over it we're in we're
like
all over it yep good stuff let's do it
well